foreign
my name is Liz and I'm in Columbus
um I found you guys about two years ago
um and I felt like I made a lot of
progress at first and then around a year
ago I think my anxiety and depression
just kind of got worse after covid
um failed relationships you know Ohio
winter is hard people disappointing
things like that
um so I actually found creating like
crafting
um you know wood paint metal glue
whatever it was my new therapy so I
don't have insurance so it was my only
therapy I guess but
um obviously creating things and being a
mess the minimalists don't exactly align
so I don't know how to keep the sense of
peace and calm I get when I express my
creativity but also be a minimalist and
kind of offload it
when I create it
um it just seems hypocritical I'm often
overwhelmed looking at Solutions or
figuring out how to offload them
um but the act of actually creating has
helped me heal and from my mind so much
TK does minimalism not align with
creating physical things oh man
minimalism is not scarcity it's
abundance rightly expressed as you often
say how might my life be better with
less it's not just the less but how
might my life be better you get rid of
things or you downsize and declutter
things only because you're trying to
make space for what really counts and so
if you're living a life of optimal
creative expression and you're delving
into your arts and your crafts and your
house is filling up with all sorts of
delightful tools that you're using and
they bring you Joy that is minimalism
because you got rid of whatever was
holding you back from indulging in what
brings you the lasting pleasure that you
desire yeah I mean we're all creating
something you know I remember at one
event someone uh is very similar s is
very similar question about her creation
she's like I don't want to sell anything
like you know I feel bad like selling my
art you know I don't want to put more
consumerism out there in the world but I
just told this one I'm like we're all
selling something like the question is
like what are you selling are you
selling something worthwhile that you
truly thinks at you think adds value to
someone else's life and I would say the
same thing to this question it's like
are you truly creating something that
you think is going to add value to
someone else's life and if you are
that's great if anything minimalism
helped her realize how important the
creativity was to her yeah and I think
where she got confused with there is
because I don't want to force anything
on to someone because that is what
consumerism does hey you'll be complete
if you buy my painting or if you buy
this pair of jeans that I created or the
shirt that I create it's going to
complete you right okay well we know
that's not true right but it doesn't
mean those things can't be valuable to
someone and so offering something
promoting something even there's nothing
inherently wrong with that you don't
want to batter people over the head with
your Creations you're going to watch
what I created no matter what yeah I'm
going to sit you down in this chair I
made a movie and you are going to see it
God that's not going to make any of us
feel good yeah TK had our last Sunday
Symposium you had this great line I
wrote it down for Liz because I thought
it was applicable here you said the joy
of being human is found in creativity
not consumption absolutely just because
you're getting rid of stuff doesn't mean
you're practicing what is at the heart
of minimalism we become truly alive when
we participate in the in the creative
process that's what makes us human we
don't find our greatest fulfillment in
just getting a bunch of stuff that's out
there and bringing it into our homes but
it's looking within and tapping into
that abundance that's within our own
souls and bringing it forth you know and
so what you're doing really strikes at
the core of everything that we talk
about and one more little thing about
this because this variation of questions
comes up a lot hey I'm really
experiencing the joys of abundance in
one area of my life how do I reconcile
that with minimalism suppose I were to
say you know what that breaks the rules
you simply cannot be a good minimalist
and enjoy that form of abundance you
know what you ought to say to that you
ought to say all right cool screw
minimalism then you ought to say screw
minimalism and I'm gonna get on with my
life I mean why is that so hard to do is
it because we feel like we have to make
YouTube videos why it was a fraud for
the past 10 years for finding usefulness
in idea X now you don't have to do that
you use an idea for as long and as much
as it works for you and if it runs into
a situation where it just doesn't
provide value sit it down until it
provides value again and go with what
works you don't have to make a YouTube
video renouncing people disassociating
from people who still find Value in it
you don't have to be an enemy of it you
don't have to change religions you just
continue to do what's healthy for you
yeah I I would never recommend someone
be a minimalist like I would never look
at someone and be like oh you know what
you need in your life minimalism like
that is not the flag that's not the hell
I'm dying on with someone imagine you
handed them a tract with those oh my God
yeah it is but it's just like the
minimalist rulebook printed out right
put a little small version of this this
will improve your life look it's funny
because yeah people think that we are
proselytizing minimalism but really for
me it's I've connected with this
philosophy it started with my stuff it
started with my debt but as we've done
this over the last 13 years and never
thought we would go this long it's like
there's you can apply that idea of
Simplicity to anything and that is what
gets me excited about minimalism now for
someone else
maybe minimalism doesn't excite them
that's okay there's we're not
prescribing it we're not trying to say
that everyone on the planet should be a
minimalist it's it's not that at all
what we're saying is hey if you feel
overwhelmed in your life especially when
it comes to your stuff this is something
that might be able to add value to your
life like it did hours it's a
description not a prescription there
goes that distinction again it's an
honest way of saying hey this is
something we're doing here's the value
we're finding in it and here are some
tools that might be useful for you too
but it's not a prescription it's not a
list of shoulds and shouldn'ts that you
stand under as if it Lords over you from
above that's not how things work it's
just like basketball I'm a basketball
fan that's not part of my identity
That's Not My Religion that's just an
accurate description of something that I
like but if tomorrow I woke up and I
found myself spontaneously bored with
the sport I would need to make an
announcement or an apology to anybody I
could simply be and enjoy that new form
of being without attachment to the label
I love what you're saying there it
reminds me of something Derek sivers
talks about he identified as part of his
identity his core identity I'm a
musician I'm a musician I'm a musician
and he held on to his guitars and his
keyboards and you know his liner notes
and all of these things that he had
created and he realized several years
had gone by and he hadn't played an
instrument
I'm a musician only if I'm playing my
instruments you're creative only if
you're creating but we often hold on to
these as part of our identity because
they become infused with who I am as a
person and to describe me I must have
the accoutrements and so if you're
creating or you have the accoutrements
for creating just because that's part of
your identity it's okay to let go but if
you're actually creating as Liz said she
creates as therapy or if you're using
minimalism as therapy or music as a
therapy I think that's a beautiful thing
yeah absolutely did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free